important reason morham is a Serial
entrepreneur he had several successful
startup companies uh and what he has
been doing systematically during his
career he was importing um Theory from
the database Theory community and um
distilling it and applying it in
practice uh one of his most famous
companies is logic blocks which created
this super optimized uh data log and
uh which is still highly referenced and
explored today so morham is going to
talk about um um his experience talking
to
theoreticians okay thanks Dan um so
earlier today I spoke about relational
and the company and tried to tell you a
little bit about what we do um today I
want to share with you more of the
Insight of like why we do what we do or
what we're trying to
do um and I love this clickbait uh talk
title I think it's very uh tailored to
the audience here today I uh I didn't
come up with it but I really liked it so
I'm I'm using it with with permission I
was asking basically hey what you guys
want me to talk about um okay so uh I
also would love for this to be a bit of
a of a pep talk you know about inventing
the future and so on lots lots of
different Futures uh we can
invent uh so one way of sort of framing
a little bit of the the future that I'm
motivated to try to help invent is goes
back to a Jim Gray's touring award
lecture in 1998 so he tried to do a very
like David Hilbert style here the grand
challenges of of computing uh type
touring award lecture and his 12th and
final goal or
challenge uh this is his slide uh was uh
for automatic programming okay so do
what I mean uh not you you know hundreds
of dollars of or hundreds of lines of
code no programming bugs so basically he
described the Holy Grail of programming
languages and systems devise a
specification language or UI that is
easy for people to express designs like
a thousand times easier uh that
computers can compile that can describe
all applications so it's complete and
then the system should reason in quotes
again his quotes about the application
and just make it happen Okay so not
uniquely a Jim Gray uh dream here the
whole communities on program synthesis
for example and other communities uh
that work on aspects of this problem uh
I think the language model uh large
language models you know were were
interesting to some folks because you
can just say you know build me a XYZ
application and it sort of builds it for
you but I think what what Jim is talking
about here is like having a
specification language of some kind of
precise uh formal specification language
that could generate uh programs uh that
were uh you know optimal useful and so
on
okay so uh so who should do this work uh
you know is it systems people is it
Theory people uh is it both okay so uh
how do we get there uh I think we all
know that it uh it should be both but
not everybody believes that um so I uh
13 years ago I was at Oxford uh we had
kicked off a workshop called the datalog
2.0 Workshop a lot of database Theory uh
people attended not many uh database
assistance people showed up and I I
endeared myself to the cloud to The
Crowd by quoting uh Moshi vardy in an
article at sigmod record and he said you
know I'm perfectly okay if someone says
very nice work but if you can change it
a little bit here maybe it will fit
better my needs rather than uh you're
wasting our time you're wasting your
time stop bothering us which I have to
say very often uh what we were hearing
this is in the context of like the
theory people uh in the community who
are being told
uh sometimes not so nicely uh that their
work is not it's not useful okay and in
fact uh I don't know if uh if Joe uh
sort of on his own or because he saw the
the the slides from the datalog 2.0
presentation uh but later that year at
pods in pods uh
2010 uh he kind of like owned up to that
a little bit and sort of try to
reconcile I think between the two
communities which is something I very
much appreciate uh so this is again his
slide and he quoted himself and Michael
Stonebreaker uh another touring Award
winner she'll be a theme here uh from a
uh a book they they um there was a
collection of basically important papers
in the database uh uh realm uh called
readings in database systems the Third
Edition uh used to say something to the
effect of no practical applications of
recursive query recursive query Theory
have been found to date I find it sad
that the theory Community is so
disconnected from reality they don't
even know how their ideas are okay so I
think this is what Moshe was talking
about I'm not entirely sure uh or uh uh
and so I think you know Joe um uh was
very uh gracious in that then he pointed
out how uh there were actually in his
experience in his lab in his research uh
over the last seven years they did a lot
of really cool work with uh recursive
query process okay so an attempt at sort
of bridging uh uh the two communities
and making sure that you know we all get
along and uh we're all working rowing in
the same
direction all right so uh you know some
level the talk is about Theory people
making a company viable or company
successful I would argue there are whole
Industries like there's a hundred
billion dollar plus industry called the
database industry that was founded by a
theory people okay so today uh you know
all operational databases are relational
we take that for granted uh but that
wasn't always the case there were uh
before relational databases existed uh
for transactional workloads or ltp
workloads or operational workloads the
real Engineers use something called
navigational databases and you have data
with pointers from one record to the
next and if you were a real engineer you
wrote cobal and you navigated through
pointers and you programmed your way
through uh uh through the job okay uh
and so you know that was the that was
the dominant model that was the the the
model that serious Engineers work with
and when the relational Model come came
out it wasn't really taken very
seriously in fact in 1974 at
siget uh these two gentlemen uh got
together to have the great debates uh
about the navigational databases versus
relational databases navigational again
is more procedural more programming
oriented database systems and at the
time this happened Charles Bachmann was
already a touring Award winner and Ted
Cod was just a theory researchers B
buried in the bowels of
IBM uh you know very early on in his
career you know going up against the
touring Award winner arguing for the
relational model okay and the basic
argument uh against the relational model
is perform performance uh it's
impossible to implement this stuff in a
in a scalable performant way uh and if
you want to be efficient you have to
follow pointers around right uh and
there's no like magic compiler that's
going to make you know query
optimization work so you know don't
waste our time with that and then the
other argument if you again read the
stuff it's all very well documented
against the relational model is
programmers won't get it because you
know programmers want to write cobal and
follow okay and the essence of Ted's
argument back was uh separation of what
from how the specification from how you
achieve it actually creates more room
for performance because you can now go
search for the plan that uh that gives
you the best performance and he's
basically saying you know programmers
are padas and you know they're not who
we should be caring about we should be
caring about end users and domain
experts and so on and they're the ones
that don't want to learn computers don't
want to learn programming and they just
want to ask a question uh uh and get
their answer okay so uh so who won uh
commercially at least in Industry uh
well we know who won um Oracle sort of
was created to go after the operational
transactional uh workload um they
actually for a point for a period in
time they weren't called Oracle they
were called relational software Inc and
at roughly the same time uh the company
that became Ingress was called
relational Technologies Inc and roughly
at the same time the company that became
INX was called relational databases Inc
uh because their interests were very
aligned at the time because they were
trying to establish the relational
movement against people who wanted to
follow pointers around okay now
eventually the movement went out and
they all rebranded because it wasn't so
much an argument anymore uh about
whether you should do uh uh you know you
should Implement transactional systems
in relational
databases Okay so first time uh at least
I see this movie Next time I saw this
movie was in the context of analytical
databases in the 90s I was actually in
this uh in this movie uh because there
raging debates about how to do analytics
is the multi-dimensional array or maybe
the tensor the basic building block for
analytics or should it be relations
again okay and the serious Engineers
were like of course it's arrays that's
how we do high performance Computing uh
you know this the relational stuff was
not designed to do do high performance
anything it's slow it's you know if
you're lucky to get a 100 transactions
per second like how can you even waste
my time with this idea of you're going
to do analytics with uh with sort of
some relational theoretical uh uh thing
okay and uh there were whole movements
there was the molap movement olap is
online analytical processing so molap
stood for multi-dimensional arrays uh
olop and then rollup okay uh and uh the
rollup Community wasn't looking so good
for it uh because you know serious
people use multi-dimensional arrays for
for performance so who won uh well you
know teradata natia companies like
Tableau uh Tableau doesn't have
relational in its name but Tableau you
know it's a it's an indirect reference
uh so to they want so dominantly that if
even if you Google molap today you don't
find many references to olap anymore uh
because it's just like the only way you
do olap is relationally
okay so uh Big Data Systems are
relational today as well that wasn't so
clear uh uh you know 10 years ago big
data is the new workload the new
dominant thing relational model is dead
the way of the future is map produced
you got to program your analytics da
there was one company at the time going
oh you know well maybe if you change the
architecture you know we can do this in
relational model and people laughed at
them and uh the former CEO of snowflake
is involved our company and he says he
really struggled to raise money as as
recently as he was turned down 26 times
or 27 times uh three years or two and a
half years before snowflake had the
largest software IPO of all
time okay so uh relational always wins
is uh sort of the key Insight here uh
why does the relational Paradigm always
wins well I think because it separates
the what from the how you get a spec
it's independent of the how you
implement the spec and then you can
automate away the hard Parts uh like
things like query optimization memory
management paralyzation transaction
management incrementalization uh it's
simply put where it applies it automates
away programming okay and this is an
observation that's been made by others
uh this is I found this sort of in the
beginning of a book by Don Bor on uh on
software engineering matters and he said
the most significant advance in
automatic programming is relational
query optimization ironically
accomplished in the late 1970s and again
talks about give me a spec and I will I
will find you uh uh a automatically find
you the implementation of that spec okay
and just I just want to very quickly
close out give me one more minute the
theme here like when does it win okay
doesn't it's never like a good choice at
the beginning because we don't have what
we need to make it work okay so when
does it win it wins when computer
scientists Theory people invent new
algorithms new data structures and more
expressive languages to support the
workload that's interesting okay so for
transactions it was inventing SQL it was
inventing the early query optimizers the
early joint algorithms the volcano style
processing the transaction management
all of that when that stuff came into
existence okay no one wanted to do that
by hand anymore right for olap uh it was
parallel joint algorithms bitmap indices
column stores vectorization these are
all techniques that had to be invented
to make it possible uh to uh support
those workloads and again once you have
that then you don't need to program and
stuff anymore for Big Data it was this
new architecture SE uh Cloud native
separating storage from compute and
adding support for uh uh immutable data
structures and so on and so as new
workloads emerge around intelligent
applications and new things like that uh
I think there's a new generation of
breakthroughs here that we're looking to
uh to take advantage of things like
worst case optimal joint algorithms
making possible to efficiently run uh
SQL careers with cylic SQL queries lots
of self-joins and things like that uh I
couldn't really do that before uh uh
semantic query optimization you heard
Remy stock earlier uh about how that can
happen and how you can improve the
astics of query processing uh efficient
incremental computation you're going to
hear from mihi uh about techniques uh in
that space uh new languages like
language that we're working on called
Drell that makes that possible New
Normal forms and so on so I'll close by
pointing out this is a list from hung
who's a colleague along with Slavic and
Mahmud and lots of people here who are
in the research network uh here's a list
of stuff that we need help with and so
hopefully some some of these uh problems
are interesting uh for you here are
folks that we're currently working with
our friends in this community I have a
longer list but these are people that
we're actively engaged with right now
and you can see a lot of folks who come
from the uh database Theory Community
algorithms Community uh uh and so on we
we of course also work with systems
people uh and uh yeah we'd love to uh
all push in this direction
thank you very much okay thank you
Mor maybe we take one question yes Alon
when do relational systems lose well uh
they they don't win when you don't have
the algorithmic and data structure
Innovations so I think we're getting to
the point where really like all the
major workloads actually can be
implemented in a relational database so
like the the architecture we've been
dealing with the last 50 years where you
have every application developed partly
in a you know defined partly in a dat
datase and partly in some procedural
programming language uh was because the
the business logic what those semantics
were not really easy to implement
aeration okay so now with these
breakthroughs I think most business
logic can be implemented and now we get
to a point where endtoend you can Define
your whole application relationally and
have the same kind of advantage that
deep learning gave us with uh with
machine learning right deep learning
before deep learning you used to have to
do symbolic feature engineering by hand
and then you would do uh you know
parameter learning uh with continuous
optimization and by making it all
endtoend differentiable you can optimize
across the whole thing and automate away
the the by hand stuff so I think if you
can Define the whole application
relationally end to end you create
opportunities for optimization across
the whole thing that you just wouldn't
be able to if you had some procedural
tour you know thing that is not amable
to
analysis okay I think this is all the
time we have so let's than more
h